all right look um i'll make this quick
because it might be a quick series
so
i'll just get out of your way and let
you uh
let you gloat
let you say you told me so
i mean because i i want to start with an
admission before i give you the floor i
just will start with an admission okay
okay all right so
game gets started
heat up by 13
and i'm like oh yeah
i'm about to look good tomorrow
i'm about to i'm about to say look here
all y'all people talking about lakers in
five and you know this is this is gonna
be over quickly i'm like yeah yeah
bruh
by the end of the first quarter because
i almost text you i almost called you
i'm like you know what i'm gonna wait
i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait for about
the first quarter the lakers had taken
the lead
yeah and then it went something like
83 to 44
over the course of two and a half
quarters which frankly
i didn't see past halftime because at
halftime i went click and i caught up on
my sleep because between sunday night
football monday night football
and the debate on tuesday night i'm like
you know what this is a wrap now come
the [ __ ] no
you said it gordon
hello
gorham draggage is now doubtful with a
torn plantar fascia bam adebayo is also
doubtful for game two of the shoulder
um
so it's doubtful that my heat and six
pick
uh actually
it was a long shot anyway given uh we
going against lebron and anthony davis
uh i was picking against them so yeah
anyway all right i'm done go ahead go
ahead and listen
can i run down the list no no let me
just run down the list you said a lot
and
what time is it you said a lot in two
minutes okay
number one
as long as you've known me michael you
know i'm not the type to gloat
i'm just not i'm not a a an i told you
so guy
most of the time stop lying wait wait
stop lying donald trump for you you did
took you 10 seconds to lie stop blowing
a minute you are the biggest trash
talker i know
oh my god
oh you got some old stuff wait that's
old stuff
you know you've changed
yeah a little bit a little bit okay
let's get this camera situation i want
to be tied up with michael we got black
shadows i don't know they must not be
feeling me right now it's split screen
yeah you know what it is um
have you changed
have you ever been a different person
thank you there we go
than the one i practically grew up with
you're a different person i'm i'm
growing i'm growing but the thing is
speaking of growing and you know aging a
little bit with you know getting some
wisdom
i know somebody hurt my feelings
now that now i can be told somebody hurt
my feelings earlier this week saying oh
you're a little old
you probably fell asleep you probably
didn't watch it and you're going to
sleep at halftime
you ain't even stand up and watch the
game you're talking about me
so i saw where it was headed
okay
and then here's the other thing but in
all seriousness mike
it's game one
okay game one now i think the lakers i
think the lakers gonna win the series
and i think they're gonna win it in five
didn't i say lakers in five
but just because they won eight uh game
one by eighteen points doesn't mean that
they're gonna that's how the whole
series is gonna go i think miami
is gonna get one of these games
they better get game two or that lakers
and five becomes lakers and four
but
the hit you mentioned the injuries you
mentioned injuries
to to uh draw judge and and to add a bio
that's not the story here's the story
they have no way of stopping my guy
anthony davis
more lies more lies but go ahead go
ahead go ahead go ahead and cook go
ahead more lies you're a guy anthony
davis all right you know i let you slide
with this for like the first couple of
weeks of the show tell him i know i know
listen i can't remind him of what she
was saying off camera about anthony
davis call him a loser
i call him a loser
i did
and but this is here's here's the story
and i don't i can't believe
we didn't see this coming
miami
gets all the credit should get all the
respect
for for what what miami did in the first
three rounds of the playoffs
it was phenomenal it really was i mean
you take out you sweep indiana uh you
take out you take out milwaukee and you
take out boston but think about all
those things all those teams they all
have some
issue at center whereas milwaukee's
center issue is they got a center who
shoots three-pointers they don't
necessarily have a guy who is going to
challenge
uh a legitimate big man who can just do
a lot of things boston
had like uh you know put it together you
know
center by numbers ennis cantor
rob williams
daniel teice guys said okay they're all
right
and uh in indiana okay
yeah you're not really thinking about
that
miami just has no answer they got this
is the this is a real situation they got
here and i just can't think of anybody
who can healthy or not anybody who can
deal with anthony davidson's side that's
going to be the story of the series now
if adebayo was out forget it forget it
man anthony davis we talk about lebron
being the finals mvp
it's going to be davis
because of the numbers the numbers are
going to be overwhelming
and not only so that's the question
he'll he'll be in the in the
conversation i mean look he's already a
first team all-nba he keeps this up
he should already he's already in the
conversation about
best player in the nba after lebron he's
in that in that group right
yeah that group will get smaller and
he'll be in it you know we'll suppose if
if he finishes his finals like this i
think more people will start talking
about anthony davis as the top three to
five talent that he is uh in the nba
right now and and nobody else
people like you who didn't appreciate
what he did in new orleans nobody else
would dare call him a loser again if he
performs like this on the biggest stage
but no already i'm already cancelling
christmas i'm already cancelling
christmas
i'm sorry what would we bout to say no
i'm just gonna say you see right there
it says uh bouquets for the prowl and
those bouquets not just saying hey
anthony davis is a great player
obviously he obviously he is
but this is what people like me have to
learn and just really have to accept i i
know it i know it here but sometimes
when the games start
and records start
are being compiled you kind of forget
that a player is no matter how great
that player is you still have to have
the support of a great organization
great teammates the right culture
and i i often i off i'm trying to get
better here but i often slip into all
right but what did this guy do what has
he done and i'll take a player in a
vacuum and not necessarily put him in
context that's what i did you reduced it
to how many times he made the playoffs
in new orleans that was that was your
go-to how many times they make the
playoffs with him in new orleans twice
all right listen
i am two times cancelling christmas
right now i'm actually impressed with
how reserved and how rational you are i
i fully expected
uh that smoke i fully expected for you
to come in and be like how dare you pick
against the king and my guy anthony
davis what
led you to think
what what listen though
so maybe i'll i will do that i'm the one
overreacting then because especially in
light of the injuries which i think we
know in the last hour that they're
listed as doubtful you talking about
taking your leading scorer
in the postseason and goran's rockets
talk about losing him or him being
compromised by a torn plantar fascia you
talk about bam out of bio
you know with a strained left shoulder
him being compromised if not losing and
you didn't mention another guy you
didn't mention it i know he played jimmy
butler playing
jimmy but yeah i mean that was a nasty
ankle turn well that's what maybe turn
it off i was like you know what when he
turned his ankle i turned it off i'm
like okay that's a wrap for the night
and looking at the layout of the series
right now i'm like it's even though i
picked them going in and it's one game i
know it's one game i know it's one game
just one game come on but that one game
man oh my god it was it was a slaughter
it was a slaughter
and
it was uh catastrophic in turn
potentially catastrophic in terms of
injuries